congrats again on a I don't think we're
quite done okay what do you got cuz uh
you know one of the reasons why I get
here early sometimes is that I really
like oh you like hearing the prediction
I like hearing the predictions okay and
you guys had some interesting ones
today so appreciate that I did take
Fabby against you but I took you against
and you've got against me twice right
yeah it's just it's content go for you
know it's
content but I mean you also have to like
you know what I mean it's definitely
hard to to pick you every time I don't I
don't take offense but I notice it
that's what I'm saying okay well you
know I think most of the players are
okay with it I think we will continue to
do it but maybe try to get it done
earlier so it doesn't feel like it's
right before the game what do you think
if it's up to me do it as the players
are hearing I think that's like that
okay well maybe that's a good lesson in
the in the the mental F and remember
like every time you bet against me I get
like a couple perc better